s'il est bien un mot qui ne rime pas
avec qu'ovide c'est tourisme le portugal
en sait quelque chose
de janvier à septembre le pays a perdu
10 millions de touristes étrangers par
rapport à 2019 soit une baisse de 74% un
manque à gagner d'autant plus important
que le tourisme représente à lui seul
8,7 pour cent du pib
le secteur hôtelier reflète bien cette
tendance au total il a accueilli 8
millions 700 mille personnes sur les
neuf premiers mois de l'année un chiffre
en baisse de 59,3 % et un effondrement
du chiffre d'affaires de près de 65% par
rapport à 2019 au grand désarroi des
premiers concernés
je travaille dans l'hôtellerie et la
restauration
et je vois mon activité sombrer petit à
petit alors que j'ai toujours eu une
attitude responsable durant cette crise
il serait temps que le gouvernement
vienne en aide à ceux qui créent de la
richesse dans ce pays déjà confiné au
printemps dernier le portugal les deux
nouveaux pour une grande partie du
territoire depuis début novembre
le gouvernement a également prononcé
l'état d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 23
novembre au moins ait opté pour un
couvre feu nocturne plus un autre à
compter de 13 heures le week end
ces mesures que le premier ministre
antonio costa juge essentiel pour
maîtriser la pandémie ne devrait donc
pas arranger les affaires des
professionnels du tourisme